Hi, my name is Michael, and I'm from Central City...I mean..
Tom: Nailed It!
(inaudible), California, so I was just wondering, you guys have introduced a lot of speedsters to the show
Like, Jay Garrick, Wally West, Jessie Quick? Are you gonna introduce Bart Allen?
And how would you do it?
Todd Helbing: Uhh...(clears throat) I mean we haven't...uh..as of now we're not but.. um..
it's, you know, it's the Flash, so, um, anything's possible.
Hey, what's up, guys? It's Spencer. (Candice: Hi!) My question is kind of a crossover question between Legends and the Flash.
How critically will Barry's decisions play a role in Legends and vice versa?
Todd Helbing: Uhh...it's, y'know, it's all one universe so they all have ripples
But those guys are travelling through time, y'know, on their own missions, so, um, they're kinda in their own timeline too.
Um, it's really..(stutters)..what we're showing is really affecting Arrow, so you'll see it on that side mostly.
Audience Member: Thanks!
Hi guys, I'm Kylie, I'm from San Diego and my question...my question was..
If you weren't cast as the role you played, what character would you like to play?
Grant: On the same show? On Flash?
Kylie: Yep
Grant: Cool
(Laughter)
Grant: Cisco? (laughter)
Jesse: I was gonna say Cisco too.(more laughter)
Danielle: Me too!! (more laughter)
Carlos: I wanna be like Harry, I think that's a great character
Tom Cavanagh: So we'll still have those interactions
(more laughter) Carlos: Exactly. We would just be flipped-flopped. (inaudible)
Tom C: Flop-flipping
Tom C(cont'd): Thanks for having us in San Diego, by the way
Danielle: Thank you. (audience cheers)
(Applause)
So, and this is, uh, this is gonna be the last question, so, okay.
Grant: Sick Cow(?)
This is it (chortles)
Grant: Cool mask, bro
Hi, um, my name's Chris, I'm from Lamorta(?), California. I just wanna ask, how did it feel to work with Kevin Smith?
Flash Panel: Arghh...
Grant: The best
Carlos: He is the man!
Grant: Yeah, the best. Yeah, he's just the most genuine guy.
Tom C: Yeah, that's a tremendous question to end it on, 'cos we, I think, collectively, just think of (the) world of Kevin Smith
and should all you people who don't like, just(?) (cheers and applause)
Tom C: Yeah, yeah, well deserved applause, he's tremendous, we love working with him.
Grant: Yeah, I mean, we worked with him towards the end of the season and he....
It's a long season and we love our job but we're tired at the end of the season, and the crew's tired
And he(Kevin Smith) came in and he uplifted everyone's spirits, and that's not a director's job.
But he did it, that was impressive
Carlos: I mean, like right before we would do a take, he would say: "Alright, best job in the world (claps hands), let's go!"
Let's do it!
Carlos: That speaks to what a "mensch" that guy is
Tom: And...
Danielle: What a mensch
Tom C: And (in) this universe, how much he's..how much he's respected..and all he's accomplished
Tom C: Just a quick nugget, one of the greatest moments I've seen on set, in our entire 2+ seasons
(cont') was when Kevin saw Grant in the Flash suit for the first time, and Kevin took 3 steps back and teared up
Grant: Teared up
Tom C : And needed to...started to hyperventilate
He's like: " Woah, it's my first time seein' this suit."
(laughter) Grant: We took a picture together before we even like shot the scene
He like needed a picture with me and like in the suit
Tom C: If it makes you excited about what you do
Grant: Yeah, he's awesome
Okay, so, as for you guys the actors, now that the Flarrowverse has grown so big, down the line
What show would you love to take your character to for a visit ?
Keiynan: Erm, I think Legends will be cool because of the time travel, you get to wear a bunch of different stuff.
See Michael Jackson, maybe? That'd be cool!
(laughter)
Candice: Erm, I think for Iris going to Supergirl over Catco (audience cheers)
Listen, I would never turn down an opportunity to work with Calista Flockhart
Jesse: I was gonna say the same thing, I would really like to reunite on-screen with Calista Flockhart
(audience cheers and applause)
Grant: Erm, well, I've done 'em all, except for Legends, I wanna do Legends, and I have the deepest love for Victor Garber. I miss being on set with that man.
Carlos: Um-hm
Tom C: Victor Garber
Grant: Yeah, man!
Tom C: Yeah
Grant: Did I just sell you on Legends? (chuckles)
Tom: Is Walking Dead part of it?
Tom C and Grant: No no no
(Panel and audience laughs)
*Grant whispers to Tom C*
Tom C: What?
What? Is it really? Oh that's weird..(lol)
Tom C: Er..Danielle?
(more laughter)
Danielle: Erm, I want to go to Supergirl too, hang out with those awesome ladies.
(more cheering and applause)
Carlos: I mean, yeah, for curiosity's sake, Supergirl, but if we're goin' outside the universe, and breaking the rules a little bit, I'm gonna go with Rick & Morty
(laughter, cheers and applause)
Carlos: Yes.
Felton: I'll second that, erm, yeah, I was curious to see what Supergirl would be like.
Host: Well, maybe you'll all have a chance. Thank you, guys, you were an incredible crowd.
Let's give it up for The Flash!!
(cheers and applause)